c'est vrai que vous commencez des fois
vos phrases par toc toc balabum
soit un bébé Gilberto bonsoir
alors voilà
quel équilibre quel équilibre plus du
loup et puis alors non
[Rires]
bienvenue à Paris merci beaucoup c'est
les classes
on dit ensemble après
alors votre famille bébé Gilberto c'est
vraiment l'aristocratie la musique
brésilienne puisque votre père c'est Joe
Gilberto un des créateurs de la bossa
nova votre mère s'est mis au chat
qui est la sœur de Chico Buarque des
hollanders
la première femme de votre père c'était
Astrud de Gilberto avec qui tu as
travaillé non j'ai chanté avec un Stroud
et ensuite votre belle-mère a travaillé
avec Stan get c'est elle qui chante dans
The Girls donc voilà donc c'est vraiment
l'aristocratie de la musique brésilienne
vous vous êtes arrivés en l'an 2000 vous
avez fait un album qui s'appelait tantôt
tempo qui a eu un joli succès en Europe
et aux USA et ce succès vous a apporté
la reconnaissance
ça vous a apporté un appartement à New
York
et puis ça vous a aussi apporté la
solitude quand même le succès non
je passe des semaines dans des chambres
d'hôtel je n'ai pas de temps pour moi
donc c'est vrai un peu solitude un peu
de solitude aujourd'hui vous faites un
deuxième album qui est très
autobiographique qui s'intitule tout
simplement des Belges Gilberto parce
qu'il est très autobiographique et vous
allez voulu dans dans cet album éviter
un petit peu les clichés de la musique
brésilienne l'étiquette bossa nova vous
avez travaillé avec Marius devris qui a
fait Bjork et Madonna donc vous éloignez
un petit peu de
m'éloigne pas vraiment de la musique
brésilienne en fait je voulais
travailler avec un producteur européen
et Marius avec travailler déjà sur des
BO que j'aimais beaucoup et donc je me
suis dit que ça pourrait peut-être
apporter quelque chose à ma musique et
puis j'ai travaillé également avec
carlinos Brown avec d'autres personnes
qui vraiment m'ont beaucoup aidé il y a
plein de belles chansons sur cette
nouvelle album il y en a une c'est la
dernière que vous avez écrite qui
s'appelle revers Song et puis il y a une
autre
quelle heure là est vraiment une chanson
dédiée à la solitude et qui s'appelle
allrown
c'est une chanson très particulière je
l'ai écrite à une période où la guerre
venait d'éclater et il y avait beaucoup
de points dans ma tête et j'ai été
inspirée par tout cela c'est une des
situations dans lesquelles finalement ne
contrôle plus rien c'est la passion et
la chanson a été créée ainsi
c'est votre cam ça quoi non j'avais
adoré le premier album déjà et donc
voilà je vais me précipiter sur le
second
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
de la chanson qui a chanté avec vous
elle m'en a parlé
[Applaudissements]
elle travaille beaucoup avec Tom Jobim
elle était très proche de Tom Jobim et
moi j'ai fait un film sur Rio et j'ai
rencontré Tom Joby mais j'ai passé une
soirée avec Tom Jobim face à la baie de
Rio avec Tom Jobim qui me jouait toutes
les toutes les bosses à Nova c'est un
des plus grands moments de ma vie quelle
chance
et puis maintenant c'est un peu tard en
plus
vous connaissez Bébel
bébé vous savez qui c'est bébé
[Musique]
est-ce que vous êtes déjà retrouvé en
caleçon suspendus un hélicoptère
est-ce que vous aimeriez avoir un fils
pilote de Formule 1
pourquoi pas vous êtes plutôt flic ou
voyou
est-ce que vous êtes toujours senti mal
aimé par les critiques de cinéma
est-ce que vous avez un petit chien
ridicule que vous tenez toujours comme
ça contre vous
non vous êtes surnommé l'homme de Rio
déjà non
c'est vrai que vous commencez des fois
vos phrases par top toc balaboum
vous avez pas pris un petit coup de
vieux récemment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'appelle des belles Gilberto
il y a une reprise là-dedans il y a une
reprise de up and Away qui est
absolument génial ah j'adore j'adore
et mettez un pouce bleu